[Musique]
première sortie officielle est déjà une
polémique
samedi plusieurs centaines de curieux se
massent dans ce centre commercial de
moselle l'événement une visite
d'amandine petit la nouvelle miss france
fraîchement élu déambulent masqués dans
les galeries avant une séance
d'autographes derrière cette vitre en
plexiglas présent ce samedi au centre
commercial best par curiosité redouane a
voulu assister à l'événement comme
plusieurs centaines de personnes une
foule compacte le sépare de miss france
sert aux mesures de distanciation
sociale des masques ont été respectées
ça certes il ya aucun problème mais on a
vu juste réellement un attroupement
autres le cdt événement est donc très
surpris les organisateurs ont dû être
dépassée selon christophe à red le
député en marche de moselle n'est pas
surpris maintenant je pense qu'il est
temps un peu de mettre de l'eau dans son
vin et quand même d'être un minimum
raisonnable d'un côté il ya la mort 150
millions de morts non pas 150 millions
que 15 millions du mont mera 15 millions
non plus merci mais dans le monde après
on est dedans
outre-rhin les vaccinodromes sont au
coeur de la stratégie sanitaire près 289
mille personnes ont déjà été vaccinées
devant l'italie la pologne et le
danemark où le taux de vaccination est
le plus élevé des pays membres de
l'union européenne le portugal
l'autriche ou encore la grèce figurent
aussi devant la france en avant dernière
position devant la belgique et les pays
bas
enfin l'arrivée de ce vaccin c'est vu
comme une lueur d'espoir dans les ehpad
mais de manière générale les français
restent très réticents
le dernier sondage dit que 58% d'entre
eux ne voudrait pas se faire vacciner
on apprend par exemple que les femmes et
les jeunes sont plus enclins à se méfier
que les hommes et les personnes âgées on
voit aussi que le milieu social et le
lieu de vie
à jouer par exemple 62 % des cadres se
vaccine ray alors que 73 % des ouvriers
s'y refuse la méfiance est aussi plus
présente par exemple dans les communes
de moins de vingt mille habitants
en
[Musique]
sma
aujourd'hui 35 français vont être tirés
au sort pour être désigné comme les
représentants du peuple auront pour
mission de s'exprimer sur la stratégie
de gouvernement au sujet de la
vaccination
choisi par le conseil économique social
et environnemental ces français seront
choisis au hasard dans un panel
représentatif et variés en termes d'âge
de sexe de diplôme ou encore de région
de résidence les plus importants
certains de ces français sélectionnés
seront également des citoyens opposés au
principe de vaccination pour que ses
représentants soit le plus en phase
possible avec l'opinion des français ça
la gadoue la banshee kaboul à débit du
baby boom et l'importance et la façon de
le dilapider du baby boom est ce que les
tire au sort peuvent refuser ce qu'ils
peuvent dire non j'ai pas envie moi
j'étais qui ressemble finalement je suis
change d'avis emmanuel macron déjà
monsieur hanouna bonne année et nerveux
personnes ensuite pour répondre à votre
question
bien sûr qu'ils peuvent refuser ce ne
sera pas obligatoire bon après si les
personnes qui refusent ne voit pas d'un
mauvais oeil l'arrivée d'un huissier
assermenté chez eux comme a déjà vécu
huit fois monsieur castaldi dirais non
il faut que les médecins et se faire
vacciner et qui se prennent en photo qui
se prennent à celle fille j'avais
suggéré ce matin pour rigoler mais
apparemment c'est repris ça peut être
repris
que mettez ça dans votre salle d'attenté
mettez une photo de vous dans votre
salle d'attenté en train de vous faire
vacciner est marquée en dessous je les
fais pourquoi pas vous le phénomène va
xi se répand sur les réseaux sociaux
ce terme né aux états unis de la
contraction de vaccins et selphy
consiste à se prendre en photo en train
de se faire vacciner contre le coc vite
19 une tendance en vogue dans le corps
médical outre atlantique avec des
variantes des clichés de son pansement
ou de son certificat 27 personnes
interpellées à marseille au cours d'un
réveillon qu'aucun oui c'est le journal
la provence qui nous l'a raconté ce
week-end 27 personnes des femmes et des
hommes verbalisé pour non respect du
couvre-feu après avoir été surpris dans
un club privé il fêté le passage à la
nouvelle année en tenues coquines qui la
provence certes ils avaient des masques
mais il était porté sur les yeux et
mais il n'était pas hydro alcoolique
[Applaudissements]
à
et dans ces cas-là elle perd quand même
ou pas non attends je laisserais pas
partir
la laissez pas partir d'accords savait
que là on est passé quand même à une
période où on est un peu sur une égalité
homme-femme chaque nom je le dis parce
que j'ai l'impression qu'il vous manque
de trois pages avec des soir
comment s'appelle la personne enfin le
chef de cette ville madame hidalgo adam
hidalgo c'est une femme qui dirige paris
une jeune femme
c'est vraiment très étonnant frédéric
savoir que la personne qui dirige tout
dans cette ville est une femme ça n'est
pas banal
vous allez pouvoir soulever la jambe de
cette demoiselle pour découvrir un petit
système à guillotine qui va permettre
cook de couper le cigare c'est pour un
petit cigare celui là c'est vraiment un
tout petit cigare est très élégant elle
ne lâche pas la mariée traîner traîne
alors la traînée a malheureusement ils
lavent pas la mariée c'est pas très
aimable pour la mariée clovis et on line
à le clovis oui bonjour coville je suis
ravi de vous parler je suis julien
courbet nous sommes en direct sur rtl et
m6 et je suis avec angelina qui va vous
expliquer pourquoi elle est avec nous
aujourd'hui en direct et la branche
accrochée
clovis n'est plus ce qu'il était
télé pour vous impressionner les toits
trop capricieux qui est doit tout à
l'heure donc oui ça l'est resté d'une
loi qui attachent toute émission
s'appelle leur être un lieu non loin de
là dans le code pénal une loi qu un
tarif tout citoyen devienne loi n'y a
pas de loi le tout trois hockey
[Musique]
je
il faut le stopper
je vous donne l'ordre de le stopper
le pays phare
[Musique]
l'amateur seuil et maintenant c'est trop
tard
en tout cas pas de pas de clip vous
voyez pas ce clip un live d'un studio
une rengaine des mots simples mais sa
vidéo cette vidéo qui sait vous
oui je me sens bien parti pour 2020 pas
s'endormir sa vie devant elle est
devenue virale en quelques coups à fond
mais par suite au 1er janvier moi c'est
ma maman poule a on voyage et devraient
aboutir amandois pas ça